bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur rtl france bruno m'égare
balle est-ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter de
l'envolée des chiffres de contamination
en france ou bien c'est avant tout le
résultat d'une ruée sur les thèses plus
de tests entraîne la détection de
davantage de 4 coded
alors j'allais dire non malheureusement
l'augmentation des cas de contamination
choristes ou à des contaminations réel
c'est que mario mikron est cinq fois
plus contagieux et les variants
précédent notamment de delta et donc de
fait avec le brassage de la population
la vie quasi-normale
d'épidémie progresse comme d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des lignes européen pour
savoir si à l'occasion des fêtes il y à
une surestimation une augmentation des
cas il faut regarder le taux de
positivité
des tests et si jamais effectivement
cette augmentation est un tout petit peu
artificiel en raison de l'augmentation
du nombre de tests effectués on verrait
le taux de positivité diminue dépistage
en france ailleurs en europe on vient de
le voir retour des restrictions masque
en extérieur en italie en grèce en
espagne couvre-feu en catalogne oberto
giovannini quel regard est ce que vous
portez sur la gestion actuelle de la
crise sanitaire en france comparé aux
mesures que prennent nos voisins
européens
mais
chaque fois qu'ils ont une paix revienne
je regrette qu'il n'a pas une
coordination européenne donc alors qu'il
importe vite entre les différents pays
et chaque pays fait une perf et
finalement ça m'allait coordination et
ça aussi ça ne permet pas de donner des
messages clairs la population ce qui est
forcément tout le monde sait qu est ce
qui se passait chez nos voisins on
s'interpelle toujours pourquoi chez des
voisins il masque et d or et elle est
acceptée en angleterre un gros gain mois
on n'avait même pas les matchs
importants publique en italie les
machines transports publics étaient
obligés depuis tout le temps donc je
trouve qu'il faudrait harmoniser nos
pratiques et donner des messages scènes
cultes et pierre à la population qui
réalité est paniqué et finalement ça
permet aussi d'aider d'avoir des doutes
society sont les bons pratique qui
ferrait les garder mystère le masque à
l'extérieur oui dans les cas où on est
vraiment fait près d'un des
rassemblements monstres et cie ont quand
même dans la rue ce dimache n'est pas
nécessaire sauf pour appeler les deux
périodes de deux des pandémies et du
coup c'est pour faire attention mais
sinon au niveau de la contamination
s'est pas le marcadal s'est passé
ailleurs que les gens ne se contaminent
donc j'ai pas que aujourd'hui c'est
qu'ils mcl du corps politique européenne
td trouvé d'accord et donner des lignes
qu'hier à la population pour leurs
assurés d'un côté et de l'autre côté
aussi pour l'éduquer passé qui est bien
mais j'étais pas bien les autorités en
france redoutent donc la multiplication
des quatre copines dans la soirée des
retrouvailles on en a parlé et puis on
voit déjà les cas de kovy 200 vols + 2
sont quatre hommes il détecte et donc ce
samedi et ça pourrait être pire à la
rentrée bono mégarde
alors évidemment on peut pas faire de
projections avec certitude néanmoins
l'épidémie va progresser tant qu'elle va
rencontrer des personnes susceptibles
d'être infectés dès lors que les chaînes
de contaminations vont se réduire parce
que le virus va rencontrer des personnes
qui ont déjà été contaminées par ne
variant mikron ou qui ont une limite est
extrêmement puissante avec le moose
teurs vaccinale et bien elle va finir
par régressé alors par analogie à ce que
à ce qui a été observé en afrique du sud
on sait que c'est une épidémie qui va
arriver massivement et sur une courte
durée il y à un mois qui séparent le
premier cas détecté du pic de l'épidémie
est par la suite nan la régression
d'épidémie relativement rapide
aujourd'hui en afrique du sud on est en
décélération avec une perte de plus de
35% de l'épidémie donc tous ces raisons
laissent espérer qu évidemment les
choses se passeront probablement au mois
de janvier uniquement mais à nouveau
c'est une analogie un peu rapide car
évidemment les conditions de vie ne sont
pas les mêmes en afrique du sud la
population est moins dense
et les plus jeunes - - comment vide en
europe on a des zones de densité de
population importante le brassage est
plus important et puis les personnes
sont plus âgés avec beaucoup comment
méditer donc il faut encore rester
extrêmement vigilant vous évoquiez
oberto giovannini le manque de
coordination européenne néanmoins on
apprend beaucoup les uns des autres
bruno merga mégarde me parlait à
l'instant du cas de l'afrique du sud on
scrute de près aussi l'évolution de la
situation au royaume uni où on dit que
le pays a quinze jours d'avancé sur la
france que disent les données
officielles en provenance de londres
aujourd'hui
alors dans quel ordre une attitude très
laxiste au départ il faut dire aussi
qu'il ya des différences entre les
comportements en anglais montre qu'il
est plus trop dans l'europe à cause du
break site
mais mon niveau du vaccin
l'angleterre est largement vacciner il a
plutôt vacciner avec le vaccin n'a qu'un
seul cas alors qu'en italie la priorité
était fait surtout
avec les actionnaires donc ça aussi il
s'adonne dédicace comme je disais aussi
dans le port du masque disons qu'ils ont
on trouvera de quoi vider l'italie que
la latitude anglaise a été beaucoup plus
laxiste par rapport à l'attitude de
canalys in italy et pour le vent les
chiffres en italie sont effrayantes il
faut pas oublier par contre si une chose
quand on lit tous ces chiffres il ya
aussi le décalage est entre l'ouverture
des écoles nitel et l'italie c'est les
pays l'ouverture des écoles à la rentrée
et la plus tardive on ouvre les écoles
fener c'est un donc forcément il ya
toujours un décalage
ceux ci on se disait c'est qui on avait
quand même des scènes trouve trois
semaines d'avancé par rapport aux autres
pays au niveau des taux de vaccinations
et au niveau des cqp passé et de ce
qu'ils ont trouvé intéressant par contre
ceux qui même en angleterre avec
toulalan compte est destiné aux riches
les taux de remplissage des rayons sont
moins importants qu avec la variante
delta et à la fin c'est une conne elle
les gros problème de cette épidémie
c'est surtout
la saturation des leaders et après des
lits d'hospitalisation mais avant tout
les leaders qui pose des problèmes
aujourd'hui le cas justement de
l'hôpital bonhomme et garba on évoque un
nombre de cadres covit qui s'envole mais
ce que cela a une répercussion
à l'hôpital ces tout derniers jours
est-ce que la pression s'est accentuée
écoutez pour le moment au niveau de
l'hôpital nous sommes en plein dans la
vague delta tous les patients qui rentre
à l'hôpital en réanimation sont
contaminés par le variant delta et ça
sera le cas jusqu'à la fin de décembre
où on va atteindre ce fameux peak
hospitalier car désormais comme vous le
savez les contaminations delta sont en
décélération même si cette baisse est
relativement lente
et donc les carreaux mikron s'il était
responsable de forme nécessitant
l'hospitalisation ou arrivé à partir du
début janvier et à ce moment là
évidemment où on verra quelle est la
répercussion exacte en termes de
morbi-mortalité comme ça a été dit par
le docteur giovanni c'est vrai que nous
allons aborder cette 10e vague omicron
avec un hôpital déjà saturé donc en
france nous disposons de 4500 lits de
réanimation et 4000 lits seront déjà
occupé par les patients ayant la commune
19 delta donc de fait nos marges de
manoeuvre sont extrêmement limitées ce
d'autant plus évidemment que
ce variant omicron va atteindre un
certain nombre de personnels soignants
donc va occasionner des arrêts de
travail et donc de fait malheureusement
je crains qu'il faille dès janvier
interrompre la totalité des programmes
opératoires non urgents pour concentrer
les forces actives et les ressources
humaines pour la prise en charge des
patients ayant lakovic 19 et dans ce
contexte préoccupant beaucoup de pays
s'interroge sur le fait de rendre la
vaccination obligatoire est ce qu'il le
faut selon vous oberto giovannini
des mois je trouve que mes plus depuis
le début si on décide que la vaccination
la part des sorties des fêtes pandémie
et on pèse les rythmes bénéfices les
hommes politiques ont dû prendre la
responsabilité de le rendre obligatoire
plutôt que jouer sous l'histoire c'est
pas obligatoire mais on va vous limitez
votre liberté mais il mettant vacciner
ou pas finalement moi je trouve que
c'est une message cacophonique et c'est
pas un message responsable c'est les
hommes politiques avec les avis des
médecins qui devaient décider s'ils
venaient une batterie nation massive
aurait été bénéfique bénéfique pour
arrêter la diffusion du virus hier ce
moment là on pèse comme toujours un
médecine qui lui les conflits contre on
est toujours en balance et on décide et
je pense que si on avait décidé dé
rendre la vaccination obligatoire
aujourd'hui on aura beaucoup moins de
problèmes au niveau des présidents des
personnes au vaccin parce qu'on aura
pris quand tout du fait qu on vaccine
les gens on prenait en compte aussi les
casses dans le futur si la rue des
problèmes liés au vaccin c'est l'état
qui s'est porté garant une complication
futur parce qu'on sait pas trop ce que
c'est vrai que les on a on a eu des
protocoles d'urgence pour la progression
des
vaccins actuels qui sont pas qu'ils sont
pas classique d'une situation dramatique
dans laquelle on rit des images et de la
lave est un péché beaucoup c'est le fait
de ne pas avoir ramené obligatoire d'un
permis de rassurer beaucoup plus les
gens bien voilà c'est obligatoire nous
l'état avec l'avis des experts on décide
que c'est important de vacciner tout le
monde et si jamais il y aura des
problèmes des complications futur on
prenait la chasse f16 les points de vue
aussi économique qui regroupe fille
fanny terre jusqu'à en train de
l'injustice une fonction plutôt bien
dans les autres pays c'est pas trop le
cas donc les gens en pression de fénay
assouvir leur poche alors en france les
autorités font choix de la
transformation du pain sanitaire en
passe vaccinale le projet de loi sera
discuté au parlement à la rentrée
pourquoi ne pas rendre clairement la
vaccination obligatoire ici en france
vont nommer gare d'alès que est ce que
vous êtes favorable
alors bien sûr je suis favorable à la
vaccination et je pense malheureusement
pour aller vers la vaccination
obligatoire il faut passer par des
étapes donc élu l'étape du pass
sanitaires
désormais c'est l'étape du pass
vaccinale en fait on laisse de moins en
moins de marge de manoeuvre possible aux
personnes qui ne souhaitent pas être
vaccinés en pratique si on décrétait la
vaccination obligatoire encore faut-il
pouvoir vacciner les gens et ça paraît
très compliqué lorsqu'une personne est
opposée de la contraindre physiquement
être vaccinés ou de lui donner des
amendes
donc je crois que c'est plutôt un bon
chemin d'y arriver de façon indirecte
il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui en période de
très forte contamination
le pass vaccinale
ne permet pas de garantir l'absence de
risque d'être contaminé
il faut donc en plus dans certains lieux
où le port du masque des pas possible en
raison de l'activité qui s'y déroulent
et bien exiger un tests virologiques
négatif pourrait y entre et d'ailleurs
c'est le sens de probablement des
décisions qui seront prises au conseil
de défense lundi prochain par le
gouvernement et nous suivons évidemment
cette heure réunion avec beaucoup
d'attention sur arte france merci à tous
les deux bruno m'égare ban chef du
service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière à paris et oberto
giovannini médecin un chirurgien